welcome to the DOMA show the show where
we talk about tips and tricks on how to
land a successful career in tech in this
show sometimes I have guests sometimes I
don't like today I don't have any guests
most of the time I will not have any
guests because you know Silicon Valley
peoples are quite busy so today we're
gonna talk about how to land your first
internship and how am I going to talk
about this I'm gonna talk about through
my lens through my experiences rather
than telling you what to do I'll just
tell you exactly what I did and not
saying that's the best way to do it but
I'm sharing my story after this video
I'm going to talk about all my other
internships like for example how to get
internships Citadel how to get an
internship at LinkedIn how to transition
into data science at Facebook and then
how to transition again in 2 p.m. at
Microsoft so yeah if you're interested
in all those companies don't forget to
press subscribe so that you get notified
when those companies come up so yeah
welcome to Jonah show before I start I
just want to say that I'm not gonna tell
you like oh yeah just work hard you know
do practice questions and stuff like
that the way I got things it's not a
hundred percent merit you know I use a
lot of my brothers connections I you
know exaggerated my resume a lot and I
also did projects that I'd never
completed but said I did so to be honest
I don't want my friends knowing and you
know it's kind of its kind of
embarrassing but you know which is what
I'm not promoting this channel to them
but I'm telling you guys cuz I want to
be fully transparent cuz or else in the
end I won't I'm only gonna be talking
about like fake [ __ ] you know and I
don't want to talk about fake [ __ ] I
just want to talk about concrete things
exactly how to get those internships
alright okay so let's get started I'm
gonna I'm gonna look at my old resume
for reference cuz it's been a while and
I don't remember what exactly I did so
yeah as you can see I have I wrote a lot
of cover letters that's how I started
but I just want to look at my resume I
think it's this one I'm not sure maybe
if I
it might be this one well yeah that's
okay so work experience I still have no
work experience I worked on McDonald's
as just a Canada I just knock on
people's doors okay let's see okay this
sounds about right
no I should take a longer one is it this
one I had multiple resumes so yes the
first thing I learned about getting
internship is they told me to make my
resume one-page cuz like they don't have
enough time to read all of them so I
have one resume where I just have
everything that I've got accomplished
but and then I shorten it depending on
if I want to apply for finance or
software okay let me just try to
remember what I did okay cool okay I
think I remember now right so my first
exposure into programming was CRC
robotics this is something that I did in
high school it's not really high school
to see Jeff because I'm from Quebec but
you don't need to know what that is
ICRC robotics basically we had to build
robots and then we compete against each
other so for example one of the test was
that you had to program your robot to
autonomously do a few things so that's
where programming came along so that was
my first exposure it was called robot
see apparently the the language it just
looks like C++ and then my brother was
also graduating from Waterloo which is
the school that was gonna go University
of Waterloo and then he told me about
computer science said oh you know you
could have this thing called code
programs where you could write stuff and
then you could input stuff and an output
stuff you know I thought was a boring
[ __ ] ever but he told me that you could
get like pretty sick jobs at Facebook
and stuff like that so yeah so then I
started learning something called doctor
racket or scheme which is [ __ ] stupid
cuz like I don't think any company uses
it so I don't know I was learning that
but apparently that's the first thing
you learn at school the first course
it's called like CS 135 or something and
then I dabble into that and then I
learned about Python what Python was so
then I was doing
like Harvard classes like online like
the really easy ones okay they're not
really easy because like I did the first
course I thought it was bomb and then
when it comes to like object oriented
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] you know I just
couldn't understand so I I didn't even
pass that level so I had a very basic
literacy of Python oh yeah true okay I
have to talk about my school because I
think that's an important piece so I
went University of Waterloo I could tell
you how I got in there but you probably
don't need to because it's super easy to
get into and Waterloo is pretty special
in the fact that you have to get you
have to do five to six internships
before you graduate so they have this
system called job mine and you have to
apply to jobs using that system like
every other semester and and it makes
getting internships a lot easier so if
you have something like that in school
make sure you take advantage of it
because that's usually how you know
you'll get your first tech internship
your first Tech internship is usually
the hardest one because you have no
experience and you only have side
projects if you have bomb-ass side
projects it's gonna be pretty easy for
you if you don't you should you know do
some you don't need to finish them to be
honest you could even lie a little bit
but just make sure that when you're
asked questions about it you can answer
them fully yeah so fast-forward to like
a year it's job fair I mean we don't
call it a job fair we have some program
called job mine where you just you know
put your resume put your cover letter
and send it to companies let me show you
something so here's the folder the
folder that I used to organize all the
applications so I had a cover letter for
each and every company it was crazy it's
basically the same thing but I just
changed the name of the company and like
the reasons why I'm a good fit I think I
got about like a few responses like
maybe 10 10 responses out of 50 and then
out of those interviews I only got like
one or I think two or three jobs I think
one that was like QA position at like
some Waterloo company I don't remember
what
with some basic [ __ ] and then I also got
a first internship which is Scotiabank
so back to my resume I'm gonna tell you
how I got that well I think I got that
first job cuz I mean it's not exactly
software engineering but we did a lot of
software engineering like I did a lot of
C++ there I did some like VBA coding
thing which is not something software
people would do but yeah so not gonna
lie the first job I got
it's not the best job ever I mean score
shebang you probably you probably don't
even know what Scotiabank is it's a
Canadian bank by the way not prestigious
at all it's it's crap to be honest but
the position was quite good it's called
credit no what was it again equity and
credit derivatives and I'll tell you a
little bit about that and how I got into
that so what credit int derivatives oh
yeah true I forgot to talk about this I
was in math and business I was in
computer science back then so I mean I
actually want to be like an investment
banker or something I didn't even want
to be a software engineer mostly I
thought I was gonna be investment banker
so or like a trader so I was really into
finance stuff and I do did two projects
so the first project is in trade so in
trade was a website that you could bet
on events so how it works is for example
if you thought Obama was gonna win the
election then you have a marketplace for
that for example if the price is at nine
and you buy at nine and Obama actually
wins the election then it will
automatically go to ten dollars so it's
one to ten or sorry zero to ten so then
you would gain $1 if you lost the
election it would go to zero so that I
mean all the money invested the nine
dollar invested you'll lose you lose a
ton o becomes zero so basically it's
kind of like a stock market ish and then
also my brother told me that oh it's
actually like a binary option I don't
want to bore you with the details but
basically in a finance world whatever I
was playing with in that website what
were binary options and he told me that
oh do you want to work on the project
together my brother and I and then I
said yeah sure why not
so then he told me oh why don't you
write a Python bot that trades these
options automatically you know I didn't
really know anything about finance but
then I learned
I learned that you could price a binary
option I just went to Wikipedia you
could Google binary option and there's
something called a black Scholes model
that you can you know input your numbers
and then kind of have a guesstimate on
how much it would cost and usually will
be pretty accurate so we did that for a
couple of months I think and it's like
it was actually a really basic bot it
was terrible actually
there was like no you know like
try-catch errors or whatever it was
pretty [ __ ] but I said I still did it
and we still made money ish so then now
I had like a pretty good fundamental
knowledge on options for trading yeah
and then the second project I did our
ITC this is a Rotman international
trading competition it's not it's not
technical at all
I mean you own you have like Excel
spreadsheets you write some VBA code to
try to like facilitate your trading I
basically wrote some VBA macros to
facilitate in our pricing of the assets
so that would get trade I did really
well on like a case that was like the
options case so I understood like calls
and puts I like it's not a lot but it's
enough to impress them as a freshmen so
I interviewed for Scotiabank I also
interviewed for other companies about
just talked up a source bank and then
what they asked me was first ask me some
C++ related questions like oh what's
object-oriented programming stuff
inheritance and stuff like that and then
they asked me some linked lists
questions I remember I think and then he
also asked me like a binary search
problem like for example can you use
binary search to find to find if a
number exists so it was a I think they
give you a an array of a sorted number
so first you know the easiest solution
would be you know just go linearly but
that would be a whole event oh yeah you
have to know like your your complexity
your time complexity stuff so then first
a brute-force ways is just like scanning
linearly and then later on DC can't do
it any better and then that's where you
pull out the binary search method and
then I think I think that's it that's
like though like the hardest questions
there so it was pretty simple because I
mean it's a finance company if you don't
ask you hard [ __ ] next they ask me some
call and put options I think they asked
they drew like a line which is like the
payout line and then they told me like
Oh
what combination of calls and puts is
that and can you tell me like how to
combine them so that your payout option
looks like that sorry I'm talking about
this because it's not really software
related but that's what they asked me
and then yeah so then I got that
question right and I went home and and
you know they called me back like a week
later and they said that I was like the
number one candidate for them and then
they want to offer me a job that was
great I got the job and that's how I got
my first internship so that's pretty
much it yeah let me see if I forgot
anything oh yeah yeah true so I guess I
did a lot of random [ __ ] too and I'll
tell you things that are kind of like
iffy that might have helped but also
might not have helped and also like that
actually didn't do but I wrote that I
did so here you could see I got a
facebook hacker cup you know I wrote a
know worldwide programming competition
hosted by Facebook develop
problem-solving skills through
completing their program puzzles I
didn't do any of them I think I did like
one or two I got one of them and then I
felt the other two like I didn't even
make it to the second round PI game I
made like a stupid-ass game using PI
yeah using PI game I think was just like
a ball that runs around and shoots like
balls at things and then Google AI
challenge oh that's the worst I didn't
do that so basically the Google AI
challenge I remember it was a as a game
of plant Wars there was another game
like this that you could play for real
like not using BOTS
it's like you have planets and then you
could shoot spaceships onto another
planet to capture it if you have more
spaceships than the other planet but
yeah so you could program a bot to play
that game but I didn't do it like I
think I just downloaded the sample bot
and change like a few parameters and
just tried it out but I couldn't like I
didn't know how to run it or like test
it and stuff so I didn't do that but I
still put it in there and also had some
stupid [ __ ] like just to fill in my
resume like poker you know because I
thought that's for trading my old
traders love poker so I talked about my
poker mom this is actually real like I'm
pretty proud of my my poker games in my
profit there I even put like my art
stuff this I don't know why I put that
oh yeah I guess I have to say that I did
get good grades in school so that might
have helped
yeah Waterloo I had like cumulative
average of 93 so I was in Dean's honours
list
so yeah I'd never be discouraged at your
first internship is [ __ ] because after
you get one good internship all the
other big companies will just come
knocking your door and you just get like
a [ __ ] ton of interviews so yeah
so in conclusion that was how I got my
first tech internship and it wasn't a
great tech internship because it was
like a no-name tech internship and it
was like C++ crap codebase was [ __ ] you
know their tech was really bad but it
was my first job and it kind of led to
how I got into Citadel and I'll talk
about that on my next video so yeah
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe if you want to know how I got
into Citadel which I will post next time
I guess and then yeah thanks for
watching
[Music]